denise image he's not in the room he's
not by the pool
not in this pot of soup these
celebrities might look good on screen
but they sound good too
that's why they've lent their voices to
tons of our favorite animated icons
did you know that the riverdale girls
got to star in the simpsons and what
about all the animated roles our
favorite avenger scarlett johansson has
taken on from the jungle book to
spongebob
we know you can't wait to find out more
so let's dive in deep behind the
animation of some of our favorite
cartoon characters
bethany's changed her look it suits her
did you know that lily reinhardt camilla
mendes and madeline petch
were all on the same episode of the
simpsons in an episode called the
hateful eight-year-olds
lisa tries to fit in with a group of
snobby rich girls named bella ella
voiced by lily sloan voiced by madeline
and tessa rose voiced by camilla
this is my crew you probably know them
all from social
the riverdale girls shared their
excitement about the iconic casting
online with
lily posting a thank you and calling the
experience an incredible surreal
blessing
meanwhile camilla encouraged everyone to
go watch her and her riverdale besties
play mean and annoying eight-year-old
girls
these are actually the very first
voiceover roles for the girls
but now that they've all tried their
hand at voice acting do you think we'll
finally get an animated episode of
riverdale
zendaya is a talented actress dancer
singer she can basically do anything
and voice acting is definitely on that
list zendaya has had a few small voice
acting roles
she voiced a duck named chi in duck duck
goose a horse named lollipop in super
buddies
and a human named fern in pixie hollow
games but her best role is probably as
the yeti michie
in small foot oh wait is that that thing
where you project a series of images in
rapid succession to a large group of
people who've come to see a good story
so
what are the highlights of voicing a
fictional bigfoot well for one sandaya
got to sing the movie's theme song
wonderful life she also got to work
alongside with shannon tatum
that's gotta make any job more fun right
but zendaya is really in it for the kids
she loves being a role model and isn't
about to stop voice acting anytime soon
speaking of hunky co-stars zac efron has
a lot more going on for him than just
his looks
like zendaya he can sing act and dance
and he's also lent his voice to some
pretty cool characters
the latest is fred from the new movie
scoob zach
loved playing fred because he got to
feel like a powerful mystery hunter
surrounded by
friends that in his own words inspired a
generation
we need office space for a headquarters
the mystery machine needs a fresh coat
of
everything and even though it's animated
we can't help but think zack would be a
perfect fred in a new live-action
scooby-doo
but being fred isn't zack's first voice
acting gig he also starred as ted
alongside taylor swift in the lorax
where the pair were hopeful that their
environmentally conscious film could
help motivate people to change the world
zac efron's scoob co-star is amanda
seyfried who voices daphne
i can't i can't breathe and we feel the
same way about amanda as we do about
zach
she could totally pull off a live-action
daphne what amanda loved most about
voicing the super sleuth is her
compassion kindness love for animals and
that she's a great role model for young
girls
and they also had scooby snacks
available to the artist
in the recording studio daphne isn't
amanda's first triad voice acting she
voiced mary katherine in 2013's epic
alongside beyonce and josh hutcherson
tom holland and will smith might seem
like they really hit it off as voices of
walter and lance in spies in disguise
hi wow uh walter becky pleasure to meet
i could get my face burned off but the
duo never actually met face to face
until
after the movie was finished but at
least their first meeting was pretty
epic
they had to pair up to solve an escape
room as promo for the new film
but other than being pigeon-loving super
spies both actors have given their
voices to animated films before
will smith was oscar in shark tale where
he co-starred with angelina jolie who
voiced lola
as for tom holland he recently starred
with another of his bffs chris pratt in
onward
the pair played brothers ian and barley
and behind the scene they actually lost
their voices from over dedicating
themselves to their roles
let us know in the comments which
bromance is your favorite
selena gomez has a lot of acting roles
under her belt but she's also slowly
becoming a voice over wizard
she voices rebellious vampire mavis in
all three hotel transylvania films with
a fourth reportedly in production
okay time for presents guys
she also got to star alongside another
disney channel alum
joe jonas in the third film he played
the very musical kraken
but before she was a vampire selena was
taking a page from zac
efron's book and bringing a dr seuss
character to life as helga
and horton hears a who she just so
happened to co-star with joey kink
who she later starred in ramona and
beezus with and who also has some pretty
impressive voice acting gigs of her own
to be proud of
joey king recently joined the riverdale
girls in the episode of the simpsons
she played addy a nicer rich girl who
tries to get lisa to hang out with her
snobby friends
yeah it's kind of embarrassing it might
have been only voice acting but the
girl's chemistry was definitely off the
charts
maybe joey king will find herself
joining the girls as a riverdale guest
star sometime soon
starring in the simpsons is a huge honor
but joey king's been voice acting for a
very long time
and joey has loved all her roles because
a kid hearing her own voice coming out
of an animated character
is pretty much a dream come true don't
worry
if you get thrown your vest will
automatically inflate so it breaks your
fault
justin timberlake and anna kendrick are
a match made in heaven
both are goofy spunky and amazingly
musical
so it's no wonder they're the co-stars
of the trolls movie with anna voicing
poppy and justin taking on the role of
branch
i could hear you from a mile away good i
was worried we weren't projecting enough
justin was also executive producer of
music for the movies
and they kept his role in the movie so
top secret that anna didn't even know
who had been cast
until he finally came in to run lines
anna joked about justin's fame on late
night with seth meyers
saying that reporters at cannes would
throw her a single question here and
there to make sure she didn't feel bad
justin's been trying his hand at voice
acting for years he voiced artie and
struck the third
maybe this guy has feelings maybe i
should cut him some slack
anna's also a big fan of animated films
she was the voice of courtney
in paranorman so i was thinking maybe we
could catch a movie sometime
nothing scary fingers crossed that she
gets a lot more offers in the future
because there's no such thing
as too much anna kendrick
chloe grace moretz might be blonde and
full of sunshine but her character in
the addams family is her polar opposite
i'm not locked up in here with you
bethany
you're locked up in here with me
chloe voices the iconic wednesday adams
and has a few interesting things to say
about her experience
first she says the highlight of filming
was playing a strange girl going through
normal teenage girl issues in a very
weird family
chloe also got to work with a few other
icons like the young finn wolfhard who
voiced pugsley
even snoop dogg was a part of the adams
family he voiced cousin
it you'd probably be surprised by how
many voice acting roles scarlett
johansson has taken on
she's truly a jack of all trades and has
been voicing iconic characters for years
she was even the voice of princess mindy
in the spongebob squarepants movie
i'm gonna be queen of the sea one day
i've learned the names of all the sea
creatures
scarlett was also the snake and caw in
the jungle book live-action movie
scarlett has also shown off her singing
voice in animated films
she played the porcupine ash in sing and
she recently took on the role of a dog
named nutmeg in the uniquely animated
isle of dogs
so next time you're watching an animated
movie and think is that scarlett
johansson
you're probably right
miley cyrus has always loved dogs so
back in her disney channel days she
signed on to voice penny in bold like
aguado i should have known it was her
first ever voiceover role
since then miley's been focusing on
music a lot more than acting or
animation
but in 2019 she did star as ashley oh in
a live-action episode of black mirror
where she got to both
act and voice a robot version of her
character her voiceover rules might be
getting weirder but it's good to know
she hasn't hung up the mic for good
you know where best is elsa from frozen
but idina's very first voice acting role
was
actually as cersei on the hercules tv
series
hi boys i'm new in town i just drifted
into my big floating island of love
idina is used to being in front of an
audience she got her start
in rent on broadway and later starred in
wicked the best and worst thing about
being a voice actor is not having an
audience
they might make work more nerve-wracking
but idina loves performing for a crowd
so it's a good thing her role as elsa
gives her lots of opportunity to hop on
stage
and belt one out avatar the last
airbender is a childhood classic
and you can still enjoy it as much as an
adult as you did when you were a kid
so it's pretty cool to find out that
child star and avatar super fan mae
whitman voices our favorite water bender
katara
no no way am i apologizing to a sour old
man like you
may is best known for her roles in
arrested development and the recent hit
good girls but she actually got her
start
appearing in independence day when she
was only eight but mei's true passion
has always been voice acting her mom is
a voice-over artist
and mae loves following in her footsteps
because she finds that animated movies
give her more freedom and
always have good vibes she lied to you
she was protecting the last waterbender
me sisterhood of the traveling pants
star america ferreira brought her fierce
girl power instincts to the voice of
astrid in how to train your dragon
get me down from here you have to give
me a chance to explain
america says that both girls and boys
can look up to astrid for her warrior
spirit
it's also super important that astrid
always goes after what she wants
while astrid has grown throughout the
franchise into an extra tough female
hero
america says that tons of things have
changed throughout the movie making
process
and that's been one of the most exciting
parts for example in the first movie
they could only have eight dragons on
screen at once
but now that technology has grown the
third movie has over 65 000 dragons on
screen
all at the same time
dakota fanning has been lending her
voice to so many characters and you
probably never knew half of these were
her
her most popular role was the voice of
coraline in the movie of the same name
i i'd love to play but
i better get home to my other mother and
we can't help but wonder if the movie
was as creepy to her
as it was to all of us thankfully her
other animated roles are a lot less
scary
she was the voice of lilo in lilo and
stitch too and she was also the voice of
a young kim possible
in kim possible a stitch in time ford
dakota voice acting seems to have been a
fun hobby when she was younger
but we hope to see her in a brand new
animated movie sometime
soon were you shocked by any of these
celebrity voices
tell us what you'd like to see your
favorite voiceover actors do next
in the comment section down below don't
forget to hit that like button
and subscribe to the things for more
thanks for watching we'll see you again
next time
you